look here's the deal you're number one
wealth building tool is your income all
of the millionaire's that we interview
unless they inherited the money which is
very very few of them less than 10% of
them inherited the money did it by
saving and investing their income they
did not give their income to Sallie Mae
they did not give their income to Best
Buy they don't get screwed around and
give their income to Lexus and Toyota
and Ford and General Motors and American
distress and Master Card who named that
anyway it's a mathematical thing when
you give your income to someone else you
don't have it anymore huh this is hard
this is hard isn't it and when you give
your income away you have given up your
economic future all for crap for a
stinking flat-screen for sign and let me
just tell you here's the deal you know
of the number of people who start
college how many graduate 52% that's an
investment in my future said the other
48 percent that are sitting at home with
no freaking degree but by god they got
the student loan debt and you know how
you get rid of Sallie Mae you either pay
her off in full or you die that's the
only way that woman goes away it's not
bankrupt able it is not an investment in
yourself to borrow even if it is an
investment we don't borrow money for
investments we don't borrow money for
investments I don't teach people to
borrow money the borrower is slave to
the lender that's what this math says
when you give up your income when you
give your income away you have nothing
all the money comes in all the money
goes out but by god we're sitting around
counting our Discover points oh we got
airline miles
Oh Sallie Mae's been with us for 15
freakin years in our spare bedroom all
because we called it in
I don't understand why it's bad it's bad
because it's stupid and your normal 70%
of the pecans are living paycheck to
paycheck that's stupid because you're
living in one of the wealthiest
countries the world has ever known and
there you sit like a rat in a wheel run
run run run run why because student
loans are an investment and I'm going to
Best Buy this is just stupid it's stupid
on steroids really seriously you've got
to stop and think the level of people's
ability to do critical thought is almost
zero good lord
[ __ ] your airline miles said no
millionaire ever really millionaires
dude I bet with thousands and thousands
of millionaires I've never met one that
said you know Dave I made my money with
my airline miles
all those Discover points broke me
through financially hey let's do the
math okay you know how you get a
thousand dollars back from discover you
spent a hundred thousand how does
spending a hundred thousand to get a
thousand back ever make you rich where
did you take your math class really
this is absolutely ludicrous but
everybody's counting their dadgum points
and everybody's trying to figure out
some way I'm getting them I'm beating up
on chase check your chases kicking your
butt their buildings bigger than yours
and their furniture is nicer than yours
you ought to have a clue by now at the
carpet and I got a car paper bigger in
your house payment some of you average
car payment America now it's $499 that's
suspiciously like 500 bucks if you take
$500 a month and invest it from age 30
to age 70 you'll have would you believe
it you're gonna have over five million
dollars and you scratch your head and
wonder why you're freaking broke God you
know what are your kids students that no
wonder your students have student loans
because you're driving a dadgum million
dollar car to me and three million
dollar car that's what it's costing you
with your stupid car payment to impress
somebody to stoplight that you will
never meet and the things going down and
value like a rock we have to stop and
think America you have to think instead
of sitting around eating skittles and
watching Oprah reruns this is stupid
we're fat and we're broke
we have no ability to do critical
thought and we don't stop and look at
what we're putting into our lives this
is nuts
it's nuts it's completely out of control
I mean the number of people I have
talked to just today with twenty five
and thirty thousand dollars out on their
stupid car it's a car good god it's a
car what does it know it takes you from
here to there now mind you having a
twenty five thousand dollar car all of
my cars cost more than twenty five
thousand but I freakin paid for them and
they're a very small percentage of my
life a very small percentage of my
income think think think
seriously so credit cards stupid stupid
student loans stupid car payments stupid
on steroids borrowing money on your
house to put granite countertops in
somebody ought to smack you that's
stupid
it's stupid you have to stop and think
again it's cuz you're killing yourself
you make enough money to retire a
millionaire or a multi-millionaire you
make enough money that your kids ought
to have a college fund fully funded and
they can go to school without being part
of the freakin student loan crisis but
by god you had to have a bass boat so
your $32,000 in debt because those fish
were outrunning you God think think
think
quit being grown-up children walking
around in grown-up buddies adults divide
I mean children walking around a grown
up buddies adults devise a plan and
follow it children do what feels good
this ridiculous impulsive nature if we
think we're gonna borrow our way into
wealth is it's out of control guys we've
got to stop this it's killing you it's
killing you well I'm sittin over here
piling up money like it's dadgum nothing
and some of you are sitting there broke
why and then going over borrow money a
bus baa
oh geez I'm gonna kill you seriously I'm
gonna go get a student loan and invest
in myself yeah you're gonna spend a
hundred and forty thousand dollars and
go in debt and get a degree in freakin
left-handed puppetry that's just dad gum
stupid it's just stupid you have to
think people you have to think quit
giving your most powerful wealth
building tool away
it's your income you're making everybody
else rich think